this video sponsored by Ray Con earbuds
you know I do hate enjoying my videos
like this but some things in zelda lore
are rather frustrating to us theorists
sometimes you think and gas and
hypothesize enough about something and
later on get to figure out that it's
actually canon and you were right the
whole time but sometimes you got to know
when you need to just stop thinking so
hard and admit that whatever's bugging
you was probably just the result of
different people designing different
aspects of the different games however
that being said sometimes the design
choices that Nintendo developers make
are so deliberate that they have got to
mean something in this case the ears of
Ganondorf
you heard me those giant fleshy pieces
of cartilage hanging off both sides of
his head what's so special about them
you ask well let's take a look at the
Ganondorf corpse from the breath of the
wild to train when watching the trailer
at first glance it's easy to miss this
peculiar little detail but if you look
closer at his facial region you'll
notice that his ears are rounded now
listening in the entire world of Hyrule
that breadth of the wild introduces that
we've all been familiar for the past
three years everybody that has ears has
pointed elf-like ears there is not a
single individual who has rounded ears
except for this corpse
except for Ganondorf so tell me why in
the world would Nintendo Cheers to
design this Ganondorf body with
distinctly different ears than any other
being in the entire world of Hyrule even
fellow members of the Gerudo well listen
in as I take a look at the weird ears of
the demon king so let's go back in time
to ocarina of time because seriously
everything always seems to come back to
this game doesn't it I mean talk about
influential but the reason we're here
right now is because this is according
to the Zelda timeline the origin of
Ganondorf the king of thieves this is
back in the day when there was one male
Gerudo born every hundred years and most
importantly for this theory back when
the Gerudo had
you guessed it rounded ears the reason
why I point this out is because as you
may have noticed and as I previously
mentioned that isn't the case anymore by
the time we get around to breath of the
wild all of the Gerudo have pointed ears
just like link zelda and every other
Hylian out there so what gives well the
book creating a champion alludes to the
Garuda's very peculiar change in both
eye color and ear shape as being due to
centuries and even millennia of
interbreeding with highly in men and for
those who don't know that's how the
all-female race of Gerudo contains once
in a guru toes life they will partner
with a highly and male to create you
know a little baby my guess is that at
that point they either just both
returned to Gerudo town to keep it
populated or maybe just the child does
or you know who knows anyway the point
is modern-day Gerudo have pointed ears
and the ancient Gerudo from the era of
time do not so that's it right this
ganon of course we see with the rounded
ears and the breath of the wild ii
trailer is a really witty and sly way to
prove that this Ganondorf is a member of
the ancient karuta it's proof that this
is the Ganondorf we know from back in
ocarina of time right
well yes but also unfortunately no you
see it would be if the first time we saw
again an orphan Ocarina of Time you know
when he was kneeling before the throne
was also the last time we saw him but
it's not and this is where things become
difficult and maybe even impossible to
explain you see by the time that you see
Ganondorf again at the end of the game
believe it or not his ears literally
morph into a different shape they're
pointed now I'm not kidding just look at
him in the seven-year time lapse link
goes through before seeing him again in
the adult era
ganondorf's hair has grown he's gotten a
bigger jewel crown thing on his forehead
and his ears have literally been
remodeled to have an additional vertice
added making them very elf like now we
should know that this strange phenomenon
was removed in the 3d remake of the game
and his ears do not change in the adult
timeline but the thing is that's not the
only time we see Ganondorf with pointed
ears after this point in ocarina of time
in the Wind Waker we get to see
Ganondorf again
and guess what his ears are like way
pointed in Twilight Princess which is
the next appearance in the child
timeline again his ears are pointed and
it's not like these are different
ganondorf's they're all the same dude
are you beginning to see now why the
corpse in the breath of the wild -
trailer having very very distinctly
rounded ears is kind of a problem but
what kind of a theorist would I be if I
didn't try to solve said problems so
let's take a look at a few different
possible answers and then you guys can
tell me what sounds most like the truth
hey guys I wanted to take a moment real
quick to thank our sponsors for this
video
Raycom by Ray J so you guys know that
I'm basically Snoop Dogg these days
right I mean I may not be as talented or
successful as he is but I do have his
favorite ear buds
introducing the new rake on everyday e25
ear buds I'm in love with them these
days because even though they start at
about half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds they sound every bit as
amazing and their new design allows for
more bass and sound quality than ever
before and since they can be custom
fitted to any ear offers six hours of
playtime per charge and their cute
little charging case can hold up to four
charges they are so perfect these days
since we're all staying indoors and
working out and video chatting from home
hands-free and without any hassle of
wires and the best part is they now come
in a variety of cool colors so if you
are interested in getting the best deal
on your own custom pair of rake on
everyday e25 ear buds click the link in
the description below or go to
www.deewr.gov.au/rjcp their pointed ears
this is even reinforced in current lore
in the book creating a champion when it
states clearly that quote hylians are
easily identified by their distinct
point
years end quote but telling us how
hylians can be identified implies that
there are other races out there that are
humanoid but also do not have pointed
ears
this theory insinuates that this is
because of the hylians all being
original descendants of heylia
you know the goddess who had initially
incarnated as zelda back in the Skyward
Sword days if this is the secret behind
the hylians elf ears then what if
ganondorf's ears became pointed in
Ocarina of Time after he received the
influence of the Triforce of power which
is related directly to the power of the
goddesses perhaps after he was defeated
at the end of Wind Waker or Twilight
Princess he lost the power and that
could be why his ears reverted back to
being rounded by the time breath of the
wild came around this theory does have a
couple holes in it though the first of
which is that hylia's power and the
Triforce is power are not necessarily
the same as hialeah is not one of the
three golden goddesses who created the
Triforce no I'm not gonna get into the
whole 4th goddess / natural force theory
right now the other hole is that this
actually would not explain ganondorf's
pointed ears in Twilight Princess you
see at the end of Ocarina of Time link
travels back in time to before Ganondorf
ever had a chance to use Link's opening
of the door of time to enter the Sacred
Realm but yet when Ganondorf is being
executed in this child timeline or
rather when the sages try to execute
Ganondorf and it doesn't go very well
he's shown already with pointed ears
although it is possible that he had
already touched the Triforce and split
the pieces sometime between the child
ending of Ocarina of Time and the start
of Twilight Princess
since the Triforce is inexplicably
already separated and within the bodies
of link zelda and Ganondorf prior to the
start of the game if his defeat at the
end of this timeline and the other
timelines also removed the Triforce from
his body then perhaps this is the ear
explanation we were looking for but
that's just one theory another way to
look at it is that the 3ds remake of
Ocarina of Time came out in 2011 right
which is after ganondorf's pointed ear
appearances right it's possible that
since they distinctly removed
ganondorf's changing air models for this
remake they could be retconning his
pointed ears as a whole and yes Wind
Waker HD and Twilight Princess HD both
came out in 2013 and 2016 and both
feature pointed ear Ganondorf
but those are both his original models
from the original releases in 2003 and
2006 the Ocarina of Time remake was a
remake meaning everything was remodeled
from the ground up and when they were
given the opportunity to remake
Ganondorf after the seven-year time
lapse they did and they gave him longer
hair a different crown jewel and even
earrings but kept his ears the same
doing away with their previous
pointyness how interesting with this
being honestly the newest original
design for Ganondorf besides the very
recent trailer corpse it's possible that
this means they Rhett conned his pointy
ears as a whole to put simply this means
that pointy ears on Ganondorf could be
non-canon the final way to look at it
and unfortunately the most likely
explanation is that it's just an easter
egg like a bunch of other landmarks and
items in breath of the wild either
non-canon or just simply doesn't matter
there's no doubt that it was a very
intentional design choice since like I
mentioned the corpse is the only
character in all of breadth of the wild
lore to have rounded ears but when you
give Ganondorf rounded ears after he's
already been shown to have pointed ears
after initially having rounded ears the
lines of logic begin to blur and it
starts looking like just different
designers taking a crack at drawing up a
new Ganondorf each time or maybe the
corpse is a new Ganondorf entirely but
that's just way too messy to try to
theorize about in this video so what do
you guys think is there a logical
explanation for ganondorf's changing
years and was it covered in this video
or not let me know in a comment below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
as always ginormous thank you to my
amazing supporters and a big welcome to
the newcomers say hello to Kin Kin
Ricola
lee go legal riffs cause vincent alpaca
and Zack enjoy your benefits guys also I
have an apology to make to FL for SH K
who do to my weird glitchy eyes I
omitted somehow from my previous videos
credits but everybody should be listed
properly now as of recording this video
that is if you're interested in joining
my elite fanbase and having access to
unique emoji and badges click the join
button below this video or the link in
the description below to find out how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so stop on by and say hi
that's all for this one so I hope you
all have a wonderful rest of your day
Masen Tony Bennett's signing out peace
[Music]